[Music]
welcome back to the Ingram angle this
morning the president tweeted this is my
500th day in office and we have
accomplished a lot many believe more
than any president in his first 500 days
he's very competitive okay
in fact most Republicans do agree based
on Gallup numbers Trump has the second
highest ratings ever by a president's
own party after the 500 day mark at 87
percent that's second only to george w
bush and that of course was after 9/11
so does this all spell some trouble for
the democrats who have already lost
their big lead in the midterm generic
election polls they're all now dead even
let's dive into that with matt slap
chairman of the American Conservative
Union and Democratic strategist good
friend of the program
Joel Payne all right we're gonna do our
report cards as well we got our report
cards but 500 days in Matt I've got to
say I thought Trump would do well I
didn't think he would do this well I did
not predict I predicted he was gonna win
the presidency I did not predict would
be it looks like projection to four plus
percent GDP next quarter confidence up
African American unemployment historic
lows that the list goes on and Jerusalem
moving the MC I mean all of this stuff I
I guess I'm kind of speechless about
that having worked in the White House or
I'm amazed that is just like the
flooding of decisions promise made
promise kept on issue after issue after
you usually don't see that presidents
like to space it out now take a breath
and this president has just done I had
to write it all down he track of it now
there's so much getting done so I agree
with you it's amazing he's impatient
patient for change now your report card
for the president do we have separate
rosters for them I think we do his
domestic policy report card you give the
president a
an a ya the reasons how do you do better
than a growing economy Neal Gorsuch on
the Supreme are you haven't you have
your own report card isn't it cute look
that's nice I love it
are you in red that's usually for an F
okay go ahead and Matt sorry I'm the red
side I think what he did with title 10
was incredibly brave past Republican
presidents have passed that buck the
Republicans are getting quietly the
Republicans in Congress might not want
to defund it or take the steps to do it
but the president's willing to do it on
issue after issue after issue don't take
the final thing rolling back are those
regulations I think that is the biggest
impact on the economy and that's why
we're growing the tax with the tax bill
and you're and it was good that was very
good but I think the regulations are
bigger I don't like the Obama
regulations had a bigger dampening on
the economy okay Joel you give a
different report card yeah I'm like the
54% of America that's not happy here on
this side of the table
46% that is happy I'm the 54% that's not
happy so okay so tell us why why you
gave him an F which yeah you you were
giving me a hard time about in the break
and I said I'm sorry that's just what it
is listen this president has been an
abject failure in any way you measure it
people entered this presidency being
able to afford their gas being a before
their health insurance they can't now
also their Social Security their
Medicare has been put at risk by this
president he has been a complete and
total washout any failure as domestic
policy president Republicans and I'm
surprised that establishment Republicans
actually haven't stood up more to this
president to fight for some of the
values that they claim they care about
well here here's an establishment
Republican Ryan Costello from
Pennsylvania
Trump won Pennsylvania first time since
as you pointed out hw1 and ninety 88
excuse me this is what he said today on
MSNBC and he's retiring let's watch
there are instances where you do see a
Republican push back in the house in the
Senate I've found myself very very
frustrated because you know we have the
right we have the left but we do have a
center and I think a lot of folks in the
center don't know what to believe and
you get your head chopped off if you're
in the middle trying to balance things
out and use some common sense he picked
up his marbles and went home he's
retiring and these a lot of these
Republicans in the House who are running
for re-election
they thought Trump was so ferocious that
is funny we have to go to foreign policy
though Joel you're a little just with
african-american unemployment at
historic low you have to give more than
that but I believe let's leave that
behind but more foreign policy you gave
him a d-plus why well and I put the plus
on there I was gonna do - enough but
actually I think the grade is more like
an incomplete I think we've got to see
what happens with North Korea listen I
am NOT a fan of this president I'll be
the first person to give him credit if
he can actually bring peace to the
Korean Peninsula if he can stabilize the
Korean Peninsula I'll give this
president credit but everything else
he's embarrassed us on a world stage
he's destabilized the Middle East three
months of his breath let me finish I'll
explain
yeah he's destabilized the Middle East
caused how was that he killed Isis off
Isis is gone yeah also also was
responsible for the deaths of a lot of
innocent women and children a couple of
weeks ago Obama never never Obama the
left trash dog Obama or drones Matt
foreign policy b-plus and I would say
most III didn't give him an A only
because he's upsetting the applecart we
got to see how it comes together I'm so
happy about Iran I'm so happy about
NAFTA I'm happy about a lot of these
changes I love North Korea but we got to
see what the next step is I think he has
a chance to be transformational on
foreign policy now it's about execution
with Bolton and Pompeyo etta side which
makes me pretty how about to a see if he
does good on Korea oh good oh oh you're
gonna see you are a tough Graham cut it
wasn't in your class now fellas I want
to quickly get your thoughts on
something that developed late today just
before we aired amid reports that many
players were refusing to show up to the
White House tomorrow
president Trump disinvited the
Philadelphia Eagles ahead of their visit
to celebrate the team's Super Bowl win
the president in a statement scolded the
team over their refusal to proudly stand
for the national anthem hand on heart
match slap was that smart to do
disinvite the people who were coming I
think I feel bad for the fans that made
the trip to be here but I tell you I
don't think there's anybody in America
that feels sorry for the NFL players I
think we're tired of this whole group
cast of characters ba it's much better
about this they can most
I was that I was at the caps game
everybody stood stand those NFL players
right even though all the Eagles stood
the entire year no one knelt no one sat
down check the Washington Times February
1st 2018 so none of them no none of them
sat down in the president because I want
to be there because they don't want to
be associated with by the way oh by the
way President Obama many people did not
come to the White House over the eight
years President Obama did he ever
disinvite one not one this guy's ass no
criticism he can't carson wentz
hopefully he can hang i actually would
have had them come I wouldn't have
disinvited me I would have had them like
okay first of all Joel he beat the
Clintons the Obamas do hire him by minus
3 million great job ok ok mister get rid
of the electoral college that's fine you
can do that next next show he beat at
the Hollywood he bought the GOP
establishment hey Claire cut the whole
field 243 she's afraid of taking on
competition Rubio Kasich Jeb Bush all of
them gone so don't tell me he's afraid
that's an unfair criticism he took on
all of them and he clear-cut the feel